but we we just don't know is that how
can we know there just aren't enough joe
biden said this joe biden was asked
about the attack he said we just
don't have enough facts
well no i don't we don't have i don't
think there is
sufficient information to know about
uh
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments so i i we just don't have
enough facts
we just don't know
i mean he told us
his reasoning and the terrorists that he
was trying to free told us her reasoning
and it was pretty clear
but we just got to wait a little longer
just to get all the facts this is joe
biden
who
you will recall
accused kyle rittenhouse of being a
white supremacist in a campaign ad kyle
rittenhouse just based on a little video
of him shooting
what we now know to be his attackers
his white attackers by the way
in kenosha wisconsin joe biden says he's
a white supremacist he says this is an
example of white supremacy didn't wait
for the facts to come out in that case
kyle rittenhouse
a white guy a white kid actually
but in this case well we just don't know
the muslim terrorists said he didn't
like the jews and the muslim terrorists
who's trying to free said she didn't
like the jews and then they took a bunch
of jews out but we don't
if only we had more information
facts go along with the liberal
narrative they are promoted
when facts can plausibly
be
contorted
and exaggerated and changed outright
even to go along with the liberal
narrative
they are promoted
such as kyle written kyle rittenhouse
was
present at a blm rally
riot i suppose and was chased away by
people and then he fired back in
self-defense
okay we can maybe we can get away with
calling him a racist that's that's how
that works when facts contradict the
liberal narrative even when they are
demonstrable facts you got it in writing
you got them dead to rights
it's much more frequent that that
happens those facts are suppressed
that's how it works
any even hint
of
a fact
or
the semblance of a fact that can justify
the liberal narrative you're going to
see it on cnn msnbc new york times
washington post it's going to be
everywhere the president of the united
states is going to be promoting it
if a terror attack occurs that
contradicts the liberal narrative it's
just gonna nothing to see here move
along move along move along
and here's the argument by the way the
argument is
yes
there are a lot of muslim terror attacks
yes
this is a big problem in america and on
american interests abroad but but
if we admit that
and it's it's i'm in this case we're
talking about muslim terror attacks but
this is true of other issues as well in
society having nothing to do with
muslims or terrorism the argument is if
we accept and admit
certain facts then americans will turn
into a savage band of animals murderous
animals into lynch mobs that will just
go around and kill innocent people who
happen to have the same race or religion
or geography or what have you
so we have to suppress the facts so that
those animal
americans don't turn into a roving band
of lynch mobs i'm so glad you liked that
clip stop before you go anywhere
ring that bell please i'd appreciate
that you'll get the notifications you'll
find all the wonderful videos that we
put out and if our friends here at
youtube don't send you those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts for
free you subscribe to
the michael knowles show you will get
the entire show uncensored too hot for
social media
check it out see you next time
[Music]
[Music]